here's another Trump win that you
probably haven't heard about some big
immigration numbers to share with you
tonight and the growing prospect of
ending chain migration once and for all
thank goodness first look at these
numbers the most complete statistical
snapshot of immigration enforcement
under President Trump border patrol
arrests have plunged to a 45 year low
down from down 24 percent from just a
year ago and meanwhile arrests of
illegals inside the country jump by 40
percent since Trump took office and it
gets better now for the first time there
is a serious effort underway in the
Senate to end chain migration this comes
directly in the heels of my interview
last week with Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell remember I was the first
one to get him to say that chain
migration needs to come to an end
the president has has said he's open to
a daca deal Tom cotton senator Perdue
have this idea of the raise act which
would have a whole bunch of things in it
including ending chain migration yeah I
agree with cotton and Perdue I'm in
favor of doing something on the dock up
front but I don't think we're to just do
that a chain migration doing something
about that diversity lottery there are
plenty of changes to the legal
immigration system it should be added to
any kind of a daca fix that we do
joining us now to discuss immigration
legislation and a lot more former energy
secretary ambassador to the UN Democrat
governor of New Mexico is a long resume
Phil Richardson governor Richardson it's
great to see you after all this time
let's talk about chain migration I know
when when you were in Congress I believe
you were in favor of chain migration and
you voted for I think it was the
Chrysler Berman Amendment was in favor
of the chain migration system are you
still in favor of chain migration given
how it was how is exponentially expanded
immigration in the United States well
you know what I'm a little troubled
laura is that I do believe that family
based migration through existing
immigration laws
is good I think there are some areas
like this lottery system that needs to
be reformed I mean I'd get rid of that I
think this situation with the the young
woman that was killed I was troubled by
the verdict in that case it's timely but
I think what we need to yeah I mean I
think what we need to focus on is is
this let's find a way for instance you
know what the h-1b visas are these are
highly skilled individuals that are
working in the United States that want
to stay here that were educated here
we're not talking about right now we're
talking about migration we can do an
hour on that well it this is this is
something different I want everyone
who's watching you got to pay attention
what we're talking about every legal
immigrant who comes into the United
States for instance this is just one
country from Mexico brings on average
this is a government statistic six
family members every two legal
immigrants they come in at green-card so
forth citizens bring in seven every to
seven Mexicans six this has exploded the
number of immigrants into the United
States which is not a merit-based system
of the idea that you can bring in adult
children because you came in on a h-1b
is preposterous that's not was the
original idea of immigration in the
United States it was for work it was for
merit and you know we don't have a
burgeoning manufacturing base back yet
at least governor Richardson we don't
you know the idea that we're we're
desperate for family based immigration
this isn't wash with anybody it's not
even a political issue I don't well well
well Laura then I don't agree with you
because I think family based immigration
what does that mean you unify the family
well why is it why a shawl I mean
civility entirely yeah you sponsor
family in your family it promotes family
reunification about the American family
legacy it integrates communities well
why America why do they all a nation of
immigrants okay those are that's a
cliche
don't work very well on this Jared pace
not just 100 years why is it you want
teachers why is it that why is it the
American worker why should the American
worker of Latino descent of European
descent wherever you came from why is it
their responsibility to import entire
families frankly in a lot of these cases
as extended families into the United
States at a time where we've had wages
flatlining and the African American
community and the Latino community what
why why is that an obligation of the
American citizen well what is what is
merit based immigration mean it doesn't
mean being that don't kid wouldn't you
rather have family members come Irish
Americans Italian Americans it's not
just Latinos you're just making it
minorities it's everybody and and and
the unit of nucleus and reunification
nuclear Emily no clear yeah no clear
husband why you pinched children under
18 not adult children aunts uncles
grandparents that's war trauma Obama was
in India actually he was in France in
India over the last week or so I want to
play a sound bite for you a very short
of something he said he was talking
about climate change let's watch did not
solve climate change but it provided us
with a framework in which for the first
time almost every nation in the world
agreed that this was a problem now I I
grant you that at the moment we have a
temporary absence of American leadership
on the issue governor whether you're
Republican or Democrat a former
president of the United States going
overseas and talking about the absence
of American leadership you support that
listen Laura president Trump criticizes
as President Obama every day it's been a
tradition of American presidents to stay
silent Obama has been silent he was
talking overseas I go overseas all the
time you know what they asked me Laura
they say why is President Trump leaving
the American economy why is he negative
on the trans-pacific partnership as a
killed American job out of NATO why does
he want to find ways that
internationally those are the questions
that come forth Laura the trans-pacific
partnership twelve countries he pulls
out China is now leading NATO in the
same way scorns of Europeans and Germans
makes no sense so you say you get that
whooshes like that Obama yeah has been
very restrained down his criticism
across in the governor you actually
think that American leadership on the
world stage
was at its apex during Obama for the
last nine years we had Benghazi we had
the Middle East in flames we had we got
rid of Mubarak we got little Qaddafi we
had the rise of the Muslim Brotherhood
the rise of Isis everything that
happened that that was all copacetic
with you Trump is a problem President
Obama was a good foreign policy
president he won a Nobel Prize Oh his
first five seconds at office you got
Iraq and Afghanistan we were respected
we're still daddy's he opened the
relationship with Cuba I think he was a
very good foreign policy president and
president Trump is an isolation is he's
an a my god governor the fact the people
watching Fox right now the fact that a
bunch of European elites at conferences
you attend and speak to I mean I'm sure
they're fun I'm sure the food is good
but the fact the fact that European
elites and other elite foreign policy
gurus around the world are criticizing
the president they used to do it to
Ronald Reagan for whom I used to work
they did it to him relentlessly he was
Ronnie Reagan he's gonna blow up the
world turned out to be one of the
greatest presidents of all time I'm not
saying Trump is Reagan but the elites
did it to Regan morning noon and night
but I love having you on the show and
it's great to see you again as always